Dwight Dewey Riley was born in 1971. he
was the firstborn of Mr Riley who we
never meet and Mrs Riley who was present
in 1996. around 1978 or 79 Dewey's
younger sister Tatum was born the Riley
family lived in the northern California
town of Woodsboro despite it being a
small town Dewey doesn't seem to have
many friends maybe his classmates moved
on to San Francisco while he stayed back
in the suburbs as a 24 year old Dewey
watched Sensational or trash new show
top story unaware that he would meet the
host Gail weathers a year later in
September 1996 Dewey was 25 years old
and in his first year as a deputy
despite carrying a badge and gun he was
receiving very little respect at work
and at home but when a gutsy murder
takes place nearby Dewey finds that he
has an opportunity to gain a little
respect the killer soon to be infamously
known as Ghostface was cutting through
his sister's high school and though he
doesn't instill a lot of faith from his
peers Deputy Dewey is going to do
everything he can even if no one else
cares because he does to learn how and
why Dewey Riley became the hero of the
scream franchise how his on-screen
relationship with Gail came true in real
life and what this could mean for future
scream installments stick around to the
end of this video
[Music]
welcome to Horror history of the two
characters initially destined to die in
the original 1996 scream it was Deputy
then private citizen then technical
advisor then Sheriff Dewey Riley who
became the hero David Arquette the actor
former professional wrestler and
certified Bob Ross instructor infused a
lot of his actual self into the
character of Dewey Riley in an interview
with variety he stated Dewey always had
this love of Clint Eastwood and wanting
to be the sort of Macho kind of tough
guy grizzled person but he never was
that's how I approached the character
from the start he tried to be tough and
the sheriff but he wouldn't get the
respect it goes back to the classic line
in the first one when I wear this badge
you treat me like a man of the law he's
really not that person you desire to be
a Clint Eastwood type of character is
reflected in Dewey's theme song which
was originally composed for the 1996
movie Broken Arrow it was used in Scream
2 as a temp track but left ultimately in
the final film as with the music Dewey's
character was kept Alive by a series of
missteps and last minute decision as the
franchise grew Dewey's life was also
shaped by the life of David Arquette
helping him evolve into the cowboy hero
of the franchise but to understand how
he got there we've got to take it back
to the ghost face origins in the late
90s
on what would have been a quiet night in
September the Woodsboro Police
Department received a 9-1-1 call that
would change everything and arrive on
the scene to find High School student
Casey Becker gutted in a tree
considering Casey was in the same class
as Dewey's sister this must have hit him
a little closer to home Dewey's early
introduction to what would become known
as the Woodsboro murders had him taking
his position as Deputy very seriously
regardless of the response from everyone
do you want to say this is the worst
crime we've seen in years even worse
than
the next morning there's a strange
feeling in the air of Woodsboro high
school as the media swarmed the quad the
sheriff brings Dewey along to
interrogate the entire School likely
because he's the youngest member of the
force and probably has familiarity with
the student body because of his sister
that's Deputy Riley today said right off
the bat we see that Dewey is struggling
to get a girl seven years his Junior to
respect his title as Deputy when
interviewing Sydney Prescott he's gently
authoritative it's a quality that would
evolve to become both his strongest
weapon and eventually it would be part
of his downfall another emergency call
comes in later that evening after Sydney
is attacked in her home and Deputy Dewey
is the first responder
foreign
Dewey steak's claim of catching Sydney's
boyfriend Billy Loomis who was found in
Sydney's house with a cell phone he
isn't that surprised that it might be
Billy evidence that he has the potential
instinct to catch criminals despite his
Barney Fife while Sid sits for another
round of questioning conducted by Dewey
let's examine his desk Cosmic cop
packaging taped to his computer monitor
orange plastic handcuffs a toy police
car and escort guy it's easy to imagine
that these were gag gifts from the other
officers basically mocking and hazing
Dewey for being the youngest of the
force but the cops do at least take him
somewhat seriously at least compared to
how he's treated by his sister God damn
it do we what did Mama tell you when I
wear this badge you treat me like a man
of the law I'm sorry Deputy Dewey boy
but we're ready to go now okay the
tremble in his voice and childish need
to look to a real adults to control
Tatum is perhaps the best example of
where Dewey stands as a man
he's Superior janitors your Superior an
analysis of Dewey can't be done without
also mentioning the franchise long
romance that developed between him and
the journalist Gail weather it's the
first encounter of these star-crossed
lovers comes as Dewey tries to sneak
Tatum and Sydney out the back door of
the police station to avoid the media
and Gail ambushes Sydney while Dewey is
busy pulling up the car
oh nice shot
despite being a fan of Gail's show he
turns a blind eye to the assault keeping
in mind what Sydney has been through
over the last year and even brings her
an ice pack for her bruised hand when
she sleeps over that night but even with
the oversight of a cop no house with a
landline is safe from a ghost face hello
leave me alone
considering the effort it took to get
Dewey up when he had pretty much just
gone to bed he must have been in a
really deep sleep or maybe just having
fun with the vacuum cleaner
foreign
any event he gets there too late the
next morning he breaks the news to
Sydney about Billy being released on
account of his phone bill being clean
and assures her that they'll find the
killer while dropping off Tatum and
Sydney at school he formally meets Gail
for the first time they have a
flirtatious exchange but while there is
an attraction between them Gail is
clearly trying to manipulate him and
compliments him on his chest because my
boyish good looks muscle mass has
increased my acceptance as a Sears
police officer again this is a theme for
Dewey throughout the franchise he
strives for Authority not as a means of
control but as a means of respect in
order to best protect the people he
loves Gail turns up the flattery but an
announcement from Principal Hembree that
suspends all classes and institutes a
town-wide curfew interrupts her Gail
pushes a little too hard in their back
and forth allowing Dewey to pick up on
her insincerity and ice her out but the
exchange still ends on a playful note
find me say so miss Weathers
you are much prettier in person from the
beginning do we saw something in Gale
that no one else saw but after the town
shuts down for curfew Dewey would make a
mistake that would haunt him for the
rest of his life
[Music]
while Tatum and Sydney shop for snacks
Dewey treats himself to an ice cream
cone and runs into Sheriff Burke the
image of sheriff Burke stress smoking
while Dewey licks an ice cream cone is a
good visual reminder of Dewey's young
naivete Sheriff Burke informs Dewey that
the Ghostface calls were issued by Neil
Prescott's phone and Dewey assures him
that he'll keep an eye on Sydney is his
botched attempt to put on his sunglasses
a foreshadowing of his future missteps
maybe not but it's still funny that
night he dropped Sydney and Tatum off at
Stu mocker's house where the Youth of
America are having a party but the eye
he's supposed to be keeping on Sid is
distracted when he runs into Gail
weathers again flustered by her presence
he foolishly allows her to join as he
checks out the party upon entering he
pretends like he's going to bust a kid
for underage drinking only to tell him
that he's kidding and to have a good
time just as he wanted Tatum to respect
him in the police station so he could be
accepted by his fellow officers he tries
to be the cool cop so he can be liked by
this group of high schoolers speaking of
Tatum she is not pleased with his ghast
what
[Music]
she doing here she's with me he's too
excited to be seen rolling with a
celebrity reporter to remember the bad
blood that Sydney has with Gail Tatum
orders him to remove Gail before heading
to the garage to get beer unfortunately
this interaction is also the last time
that Dewey would ever see his sister
alive
[Music]
shortly after he gets a report of an
abandoned car up the road and uses it as
an opportunity to take Gail Weathers On
A little murder night stroll she obliges
in the two head off this time the
flirtation has a little bit more
sincerity and they share a little bit
about themselves while also physically
getting closer part of the strength of
Dewey and Gail's relationship was each
of them willing to be vulnerable with
each other so early on he even shares
his real name with her explaining that
the nickname Dewey is just something he
got stuck with it's just this town's way
of not taking me serious
what about Gail Weathers
it sounds like I'm a meteorologist or
something and speaking of Dewey's
Authority not being taken seriously two
cars full of teens barrel down the road
on route to Turning Dewey and Gail into
pedestrian casualties and he tries to
somehow get the cars to freeze which is
ineffective so he throws himself and
Gail out of the way at the last second
lying in a ditch together and Dewey and
Gail gaze at each other before sharing
their first kiss which he allows to go
on momentarily before pulling away and
telling her that he's on duty it's a
great moment of maturity for him like
earlier when he stopped to get ice cream
while keeping an eye on Sydney he got
distracted momentarily but this time he
quickly corrects course after Gill
notices the abandoned car and Dewey
recognizes it as Neil Prescott's
basically concluding that Sydney's
father is ghost face and rushes with
Gail back to the party in the time they
were gone the party guest mostly cleared
out save for the important characters
and the house is quiet Dewey instructs
Gail to call for backup before charging
in a gun drawn as he clears each room
it's obvious he's very scared by the
Tremor of his gun and his fright at the
screaming coming from a movie in the
other room it's a testament to his
bravery but also to his objective to
protect and serve no matter the risk at
some point while searching the house Stu
must have snuck up on him while under
the disguise of the ghost face mask and
stuck a knife into his back but even
that doesn't stop him from trying to
respond to Sydney's screams for help
keyword trying
really and that was the end of Deputy
Dwight Dewey Reilly or it would have
been if David Arquette hadn't been so
good in the role as original writer
Kevin Williamson recounted during the
course of the movie we realized how his
performance was just so witty he played
it with such heart such commitment and
everyone kept thinking that about
halfway through it they were asking me
about a sequel because I had already
written the outline they were like what
about the sequel why isn't Dewey in the
sequel and so just in case we filmed
that last sequence of him getting in the
ambulance the decision to keep Dewey
alive would become the major shaping
force on the entire scream franchise and
Link the fictional events to our Real
Worlds through the actor David R Katz
and it starts with what happens next
shortly after regaining Consciousness
Dewey would have found out about his
sister's death and I'd imagine that
failure to protect her could be part of
the reason that he decided to leave the
Woodsboro police force shortly after
along with his injuries due to the nerve
damage on his back he would develop a
limp but letting go of the badge does
not mean letting go of his desire to
protect but those who needed protection
didn't stick around for long Sydney and
Randy would seemingly graduate early and
head off to Windsor College in Ohio Gail
would take off back to New York after
all they did just meet two days prior
barely there she would finish up her
book The Woodsboro murders which Dewey
was excited to read only to find that
she had portrayed him as a complete
idiot the book was adapted into a movie
stab which Dewey doesn't show that much
interest in despite being portrayed by
David Schwimmer from France that's
honestly understandable it's a movie
about the worst moments of his life
seeing it alone with none of the other
people involved wouldn't have been much
fun but the movie actually creates an
opportunity for a reunion on April 13th
1997 Dewey sees a report from Windsor
College in Ohio regarding the murder of
two students the night before at an
early screening of staff so he got on
the first flight he could find where a
year ago we'd rarely seen him out of
uniform this Dewey isn't a baggy jacket
holding his right arm awkwardly at his
side with a heavy limp judging from
their reunion Sydney and Dewey haven't
seen each other in a while and later
Randy asks about Dewey's limp and arm
indicating that he hadn't been in touch
since the Woodsboro murders there may be
an explanation for this since scream
takes place in September 1996 as
evidenced by these calendars among other
things and Scream 2 takes place in April
1997 which is clearly shown on the movie
theater Marquee we can assume that
Sydney and Randy didn't make it to the
end of the 96-97 high school year and
instead were allowed to graduate early
and go directly to college where they
could begin on a winter turn a change of
scenery would be healthy for them even
if it means not having Time to Say
Goodbye to Dewey their reunion however
could certainly have occurred under
happier circumstances
[Music]
when do we find Sydney at her college
campus he doesn't share what he's
specifically been doing for the last
year but it's safe to assume that it's
been a lonely one I just worry look Sid
if there is some freaked out psycho
trying to follow on Billy loomis's
footsteps you probably already know
or her
or them he's completely right and even
tries to make her aware to be on the
lookout for a white male which is
statistically the most probable for a
serial killer
wait a minute Dewey employers that need
to be careful and assures her that he'll
be hanging around just in case I always
took his involvement to be kind of a
cope for him he wasn't able to save
Tatum so he's gonna try to make up for
it by Saving her best friend Sydney has
a similar take Deputy Julie was bro's
finest what's he doing here he's worried
our surrogate Big Brother it wouldn't be
the last time he tried to cope using a
surrogate it was his care for Sydney
though that brought him out to the
Midwest but he'd also run into someone
he didn't care to see page 32
Deputy Dewey filled the room with his
Barney fight fish presence
you read my book yes I do read Miss
weathers oh do we don't take it so
seriously
the character in a book page 41.
Deputy Dewey ooze with inexperience to
be fair Dewey did literally the opposite
of what he was told to do by the sheriff
in Woodsboro he left Sydney and Tatum at
the party and walked off with Gail down
the road it's all part of the ride but
Gail had a point however he feels
justified in calling her money hungry
and heartless on the other hand he's
probably the only one who can speak to
gal like that without her going nuclear
how do you know that my dim-witted
inexperience isn't merely a subtle form
of manipulation he used to lower
people's expectations thereby enhancing
my ability to effectively maneuver
within any given situation
because your sister wouldn't be dead
Dewey is harboring a lot of pain over
his characterization in Gail's book and
who can blame it the year before he
vented to Gail about how he was just
trying to get people to call him Dwight
or at least deputy and what does she do
to the man who risked his life for her
she sees to it that the whole world
disrespects him by portraying him as a
doofus in her widely published book talk
about kicking a [__] when he's down
and despite all of that he still can't
help himself from complimenting her hair
nice streaks that night student CeCe
Cooper is stabbed and thrown from the
top of her sorority house and Ghostface
goes after Sydney shortly after Dewey
gives Chase but with his limp Ghostface
slips away after leaving a slice in
Derek's arm to remember him by Dewey
grow suspicious of Derek's near miss and
can't help but play detective when
speaking to Windsor's police chief do
you think someone's trying to duplicate
Woods bro it looks like it I think you
have a copycat on your hands so Dewey
does some of his own investigating with
Woodsboro Survivor film expert and
Windsor College film student Randy Meeks
the two run through possible suspects
including Derek and themselves yet Dewey
box at the idea of Gail being a suspect
he enjoys cutting her down a little but
in the end he's more willing to make
himself a suspect than assume that Gail
is a Ghost Face Killer now kills a lot
of things but Gil's not a killer later
on the quad they continue sharing
theories which all amount to
incredulously accepting that these are
Woodsboro copycat killings the first
mention of Tatum by name causes Dewey to
wince confirming that there's grief and
possibly guilt still there before he has
time to process that gill gets an
incoming Ghostface call of her own and
Randy picks it up seeing an opportunity
Gail and Dewey partner off leaving Randy
to keep Ghostface on the line while they
try to search for him after assaulting
several strangers it Dawns on them that
they have no idea where Randy is while
being pursued by a killer and Randy
becomes the next victim under Dewey's
watch just like Tatum seven months prior
that would not be the only similarity to
1996. Cotton weary the number one
suspect at the time is released much
like Billy Loomis the campus is given an
evening curfew Dewey swears cotton or
not that he'll find the guy responsible
and just when it feels like the story
might unfold just as it did before Gail
adds a shocking twist she takes
responsibility for herself I feel bad do
we
but I feel bad now this is huge without
Gail's sincerity the two can't fully
establish the trust needed to get them
through the next couple installments at
first Dewey is mistrustful thinking that
she's performing but in the end they
come together out of their Mutual desire
to bring the culprit to Justice it is
perhaps their most important scene
together because from here on out Dewey
and Gail became fully intertwined in the
series their teamwork quickly pays off
when they realize that Gail has
crowdfooted shot for her story which
they realize might be an excellent place
to start looking for the killer a VHS
viewing session in the film's lecture
hall leads to Gail apologizing for
hurting Dewey's feelings which leads to
an impromptu tryst and like their moment
together before finding Neil Prescott's
car Gail comes to a realization
do we
that's not my footage someone is playing
this additional footage on a second TV
and inevitably Dewey and Gail find
themselves in an old-fashioned Ghostface
Pursuit they end up separated with Gail
accidentally trapping herself in a
recording studio with only one exit she
successfully Dodges Ghost Face slipping
into the soundproof side of the studio
Dewey unfortunately enters on the other
side unaware that ghost face is in the
room just as he peers through the window
searching for Gail Ghostface jams the
knife into Dewey's bag with the last of
his strength the Dewey finds the mic to
yell out a warning to Gail before he's
dispatched on the glass beside her it
seemed to the events of Woodsboro past
really weren't repeating themselves
because once again Dewey would find
himself out of commission for the finale
but luckily once again he leaves the
next morning in an ambulance not a body
bag we see how far Dewey and Gail's
relationship has come when she
immediately drops her news microphone at
the sight of him unlike their previous
Adventure where she was more concerned
with getting the shot according to this
first responder it was actually Dewey's
traumatic past that saved his life
scar tissue right after realizing how
much they cared about each other the two
would try to make it work by living in
Woodsboro where Gail took care of him
until he was well but Gail weathers has
never been a small town character and
she never misses an opportunity to say
this while Dewey can't seem to go
anywhere without bringing Woodsboro with
him if one of them wasn't willing to
relocate then it was never going to work
romantically in the long term after a
year Gail left to chase an opportunity
on 60 Minutes too ironically being the
only core Legacy character to
consistently return to Woodsboro
probably made it easy for the stab 3
production team to find him sometime
after Gail leaves Dewey accepts an out
of town job himself in Hollywood or at
least Studio City due to his first-hand
experience he comes on to stab 3 as a
technical advisor this is kind of a 180
for him considering he showed no
interest in the stab franchise before
this but he was probably lonely after
things didn't work with Gail and the
cast of this movie pretending to be his
friends were the closest he could have
to actually having those friends
together inevitably they were not the
only remnants of his past to be found on
this production the return of Ghostface
would wreak havoc on more more than just
the shooting schedule
in July 1999 Dewey serves as the
technical advisor on a recreated set
version of Woodsboro Frozen at each
brutal murder including his sister
surely that can't be helpful for his
grief processing despite this it's not
hard to figure out why the job is
attractive for him he has a little
authority on set plus he works most
closely with actress Jennifer Jolie who
happens to be playing Gale weathers just
as Sydney had become sort of a surrogate
sister for him during scream 2. Jennifer
is his surrogate girlfriend though I'm
pretty sure it's more of an emotional
surrogate than a physical one with
Jennifer referring to Dewey as her Rock
he ends up moving into a trailer on her
property which if you know LA and
housing costs is probably the nicest
thing anyone's ever done for him Sydney
has moved into a life of seclusion with
her whereabouts hidden from everyone
except Dewey who seems to be his most
focused when he knows that she's safe
Dewey isn't the only former Woodsboro
resident on staff cotton weary is set to
make a cameo in the movie as himself
that is until he becomes the victim of
yet another Ghostface Killer this
prompts LA detective Mark Kincaid do
hire the real Gale weathers seeing as
how she literally wrote the book kind of
Ghostface placing her directly in the
path of Dewey Riley well surprise
surprise someone dies and Gail comes
running this is a confident maybe even
happier Dewey than the morose broken man
who showed up on campus in 1997. I'm not
suggesting that living on a movie star's
driveway because she reminds him of
someone he loves is the ultimate dream
for him but I think his slightly
improved state is probably tied to our
main through line in this video after
surviving two Ghostface attacks Dewey
has gained a little respect the actors
see him as the real thing Dewey grins at
his Tom Prince casting in stab 3 despite
Gail's incredulous laugh that alone is
proof that he no longer needs to hang on
her everywhere that night Ghostface
stabs again taking out another cast
member the next day Dewey and Gail sit
down to lunch and Dewey looks perturbed
when she reveals that the police
approached her to help investigate the
new murders sure Gail wrote The
Definitive book on the Woodsboro murders
but Dewey was actually a cop there are
reasons why they might approach Gail
over Dewey like the fact that Dewey is a
part of the production and is probably a
suspect but from his point of view he
just got overlooked for the person he
almost died for you said you'd never
leave Woodsboro
Dewey to come with her but in his mind
she wanted to be someone else and didn't
try to make it work in Woodsboro he's
deflecting from the reality that it was
Dewey who never tried to meet her
halfway in the Romantic life when it
comes to catching Ghostface however he's
all in off the Record he fills Gail in
on the information he has but he's
interrupted by a page from Jennifer
Jolie he gives Gayle the same line he
gave her after their first kiss
do we where are you going a distraught
Jennifer catches Dewey up on the second
victim Sarah Darling and the pattern is
revealed each victim has been taken out
in the same order as the deaths and the
stab 3 script and next up is Gail which
means trouble for Jennifer Dewey tries
to take control of the situation using
the authority and respect he's fostered
as a former law enforcement hero however
not everyone sees him the same way he
sees himself it do drop
you can have a word Jennifer's bodyguard
Stephen Stone still speaks down to him
and reminds him who the professional
celebrity guard is and who the failed
cop whose resume reads like an obituary
is
ouch I absolutely love the nickname
dewdrop though with stone taking care of
Jennifer Dewey joins detective Kincaid
and the LAPD down at the stab 3
production office where he's reminded
that there were three versions of the
script thus three different people that
could die next due to all the unknowns
production on stab 3 is canceled so the
remaining cast members all meet back at
Jennifer jolies for a gloomy rap party
if you want to call it that turns out
Gathering all the possible victims in
one house wasn't the perfect idea and
this leads to a ghost face attack
Stephen Stone gets a knife in Dewey's
trailer who's the Dew Drop now he
manages to stagger out to the front door
where he collapses in front of everybody
sending the whole cast into a panic
suddenly new script Pages start coming
in on Jennifer's fax machine Dewey
realizes it's a trap and orders everyone
to go outside but his Hollywood
counterparts Tom Prince lets his
curiosity get the better of him which
ends up being a fatal mistake
the blast propels Dewey Jennifer and
Gail downhill splitting the party up he
finds himself in a real Sophie's Choice
with Jennifer calling for him from One
Direction and Gail from the other he
doesn't hesitate before marching towards
Gail the real gal and reaches her just
in time to fire off a shot and save her
from ghost films thanks for saving
[Music]
next day Sydney finally arrives in Los
Angeles hoping to help solve the mystery
and shortly after they receive a video
containing the rules of surviving the
rare horror Trilogy by none other than
the deceased Randy Meeks unlike when
Randy tried to deliver the rules to him
at Windsor College two years prior and
Dewey interrupted him to get to the
point this time he's taking notes this
really emphasizes Dewey's growing belief
in the rules and thus his willingness to
learn them he's not just randomly
searching for a killer he's learning how
they operate with a more focused
Direction provided by Randy rip Gail
unsurprisingly splits off do you want us
to come with you I work better alone no
history says you really doubt meanwhile
Dewey is doing his own investigating on
set when he hears Sydney calling for it
he fights through his nerve damage to
reach her as fast as he can but the
second Dewey hobbles in Ghostface runs
off the whole thing is a parallel of
Billy's first attack on Sid and Dewey is
the first responder on the scene in both
instances once Sydney is settled at the
precinct and following a confrontation
with stab's producer about Maureen
Prescott's past in Hollywood Dewey Gail
and Jennifer head off to the birthday
party of Roman the director of stab 3.
and it's totally not Ghostface or
Sydney's half-brother the party splits
up again because they just never learn
but Dewey and Gail stay back to wait for
Sydney to arrive where they discover
ghost face mask cell phone and voice
changer then they split up because they
just never learn Gail and Jennifer only
managed to find him moments before he
gets popped by Ghost Face who slices him
on the arm and knocks him out of
commission just long enough to take two
more victims from the stab 3 cast as he
comes to and examines his injuries Gail
brings him his gun or someone's gun I've
kind of lost track at this point and he
sees the bedroom mirror moving he risks
the seven years of bad luck by shooting
through it and Jennifer comes crashing
through the glass shards or should I say
Jennifer's Body Dewey is mortified to
lose the cast member he connected most
with and Gail is even more mortified to
see the Grim image of someone who is
supposed to be portraying her so they do
the most logical thing anyone would do
in the scenario not really they split up
again when he realizes he can't find her
he freaks out Yale calls his phone and
tells him that she's trapped in the base
but because of the voice changer he
second guesses this suspicious that it
may be the killer trying to lure him
down there however when he hears her
scream movie title he opens the basement
door anyway and Ghostface knocks him out
with the Dual end of a knight as a
result Dewey and Gail are captured by
Ghostface but luckily for them he keeps
them alive to use his base to lure in
his main target Sydney and dewdrop can
only watch as Ghostface chases her into
the secret screening room where all
would be revealed it was Roman who is
also Sydney's half-brother sorry I lied
[Music]
after Breaking Free from the chair he is
bound in Dewey freeze Gale and retrieves
the gun from detective Kincaid who has
also been injured by Roman Dewey ends up
being the last cop standing perhaps this
gave him the confidence to return to the
police force in the future or perhaps it
was the heroics that would soon follow
after barging into the library and
sticking a pair of tweezers in the
outlet to turn off the power don't try
that at home he's able to navigate the
secret corridors of the mansion and RAM
down the screening room door right after
the conclusion of Sid's battle with
Roman this time he demonstrates that he
really was paying attention during
Randy's tape because he's the one to
remind the others of the horror movie
rules this time about the killer being
superhuman at the end of a Trilogy as
usual Randy was spot on
[Music]
third time's a charm I guess this time a
Dewey stays in the game long enough and
finally gets to be the hero sometime
later the group returns to Sydney's
remote home in the Hills to help her
settle back in I suppose knowing that
this adventure is over and with Roman
gone possibly for good he probably
realizes that his time with Gail will be
coming to a close soon if he doesn't
make a move he asked her to sign his
copy of the Woodsboro murders only when
she opens it up she finds an Andy
Dufresne style proposal
because I know it'll never work yes you
know it'll never work
what I'm asking is
just to see if we're wrong they weren't
wrong
what they weren't however the two did go
on to get married in 2001 and things
would go well for a while with the
Superstar limo of scream sequels behind
them the New Millennium was much quieter
and more peaceful for Dewey and Gail
they settled down together in Woodsboro
with Gail finally giving a chance to
that dreaded small town life as I
alluded to earlier Dewey became a cop
again and this time he quickly rose up
through the ranks due to his extensive
experience as years went by without a
new ghost face his younger reputation of
Deputy Dewey boy and dewdrop slowly
faded to memory eventually he became
woodsboro's sheriff finally achieving
the strongest symbol of respect he had
long sought after Dewey maintains his
care and protectiveness over his loved
ones though Sydney is of course not in
Woodsboro regardless he holds on to his
surrogate brother role and reads
Sydney's book out of Darkness cover to
cover when it comes out as the added
responsibilities of his job began to
require more of him cracks start to show
in his relationship with Gail who is
having a hard time finding her purpose
after moving from non-fiction to fiction
and suffering from writer's block which
is made worse by the law lack of a
friend Network in the area in September
2011 and I'm basing that date on this
line from scrim 2022. Sheriff Riley
wakes up and goes on his way but the
morning begins with a haunting
similarity to the night of the Woodsboro
murders with a teenager blowing past him
at an alarming speed it's also the
anniversary of the day he lost his
sister which means kids have decorated
the Town Square with Ghostface
paraphernalia he shows up to find his
Deputy Judy Hicks already at work
removing them she's harboring a not so
secret crush on Sheriff Riley but he's
staying faithful to gal and if he didn't
go for Jennifer Jolie when he was single
he's probably not straying from Gail at
this point they get a call on the radio
about two teenage girls who were stabbed
the night before and quickly go to
investigate Deputy Hicks traces a phone
call from the scene of the crime to a
bookstore which just happens to be where
Sidney Prescott is doing a signing for
her new publication out of Darkness
Dewey discovers evidence from the
previous night's crime planted in
Sydney's rental car guess she's not
getting that deposit back although he
doesn't really suspect her he takes Sid
back to the precinct for mandatory
questioning and to add to the drama he
has to break up an argument between his
jealous wife and Deputy hex Gail blows
up on him because she expects to be part
of the investigation just like in the
past but now that Dewey is Sheriff he's
technically not supposed to divulge
police information to a reporter and
he's forced to send her off this is a
major moment for Dewey perhaps the
biggest mistake he made in the first
investigation was letting Gail distract
him while he was on duty even if they
are better off as a team he's showing
that he takes his Newfound
responsibility seriously when Miguel
declares that she's going rogue the
expression of hurt on his face says it
all he's risking what's left of his
relationship by sticking to the law
eventually he's gonna have to choose
between being the perfect sheriff or
being the perfect husband for now he
places 24-hour police surveillance on
Sydney for her protection but that
doesn't stop the new Ghostface from
taking another teenage victim nearby so
Sheriff Riley finds himself in the
unenviable position of telling his
community it's going to be fine when he
very much knows it may not be as the
killer would immediately demonstrate
when Sydney's literary publicist is
thrown off a parking garage in the
middle of his press conference although
being sheriff in the midst of a Scream
movie is basically a lose-lose situation
it's cool to see a Dewey in action
calling the shots he's come a long way
from the 25 year olds taking orders and
doing grunt work however his position
requires him to conduct himself in a
certain manner as opposed to Gail who
can use less Orthodox methods Dewey
later receives a call from her as she's
staking out the stabathon filmfast a
gathering of high school film Buffs to
celebrate the stab franchise and she
thinks the Killer is about to strike he
mocks her from needing his help after
going rogue causing her to pout and hang
up he immediately realizes the danger
she's in and rushes to her location only
to find her car where he spots Ghostface
sneaking up on her in the monitor unable
to do anything about it he rushes into
the barn where sabathon is being held
and fires a shot in the mass Killer's
Direction but not before Ghostface takes
the name of the event literally and
stabs Gail in the shoulder Dewey's
concern for his wife trumps his need to
catch the killer so he attends to her as
Ghostface gets away jogging next to Gail
as she's wield to an ambulance Dewey has
an epiphany perhaps thinking over the
two times Gail had to do the same for
him that is watching him go away on a
stretcher Dewey makes pledge no more on
your own
it's you and me forever not a promise he
could keep anyway Deputy Hicks calls
with more Grim news Sydney's Aunt Kate
Roberts has lost her life along with two
of Dewey's officers Haas and Perkins
without hesitation Sheriff Riley hits
the lights hears the siren and speeds
off to meet Judy at Mrs Roberts home
which is not the right spot as he finds
out when he gets a panicked phone call
from Sydney who explains that she's at
Kirby Reed's house and the Killer is in
the vicinity notice how Sydney doesn't
call 9-1-1 she just calls Dewey directly
I hope to have that level of notoriety
one day I I mean I I do I do right now
don't [__] with me Dewey orders Deputy
Judy to send all units to 329 Whispering
Lane Dewey is no longer the lone cowboy
he once was but this new pair of killers
are a different breed than Billy Loomis
and Stu mocker were and the Brigade of
officers could not possibly contend with
what they would find
thank you
Dewey and the police arrive only to find
out that they were too late when they
get to Kirby's house they find nothing
but a living room full of victims or so
it seems the survivors Jill Sydney and
Kirby are transferred to the hospital
the only one who is conscious is Jill
and she has an oddly unenthusiastic
reaction to learning that Sydney was
still alive this doesn't showcase
Dewey's ineptitude as much as it
highlights how he and Gail really do
work better together than apart which is
proven shortly after when Dewey stops by
her room she asked if you were okay
she thinks you guys should write a book
together with your matching wounds
my shoe was stabbed in the shoulder
how did she know I was too Dewey and
Gail realize it at the same time Jill
would not know where Yale Stab Wound was
unless she was in League with the one
who created it he rushes back to
Sydney's room where he's greeted with a
bedpan to the face and beaten down until
he's out cold like his first two
go-arounds with Ghostface he stays down
for the entire finale
ask but for the fourth time now with the
trio this time accompanied by Deputy
Hicks are able to take down their
deranged adversaries he may not have
realized it at the time but this was the
tail end of the golden era of Dewey
Riley he has Gail Sydney is safe and he
has a competent Deputy working for him
in Hicks he and Gail recommitted to each
other but at some point over the next
decade Gail's claustrophobia pertaining
to small town America creeped up and
threatened their relationship once more
this time it was Dewey who had to make
concessions and he left his hometown
behind to move to New York City where
Gail would become the host of good
morning with Gale weather for all of
about two months before giving up on the
marriage to return to Woodsboro for
someone who's supposed to be the bravest
character in the franchise he doesn't do
too well outside of his comfort zone
whereas Gail lasted more than 12 years
outside of hers his old job was waiting
for him probably held in the interim by
Deputy Judy Hicks as you would expect
for the man who is basically a Woodsboro
folk hero but the splits from Gale seems
to just break him with his growing
disconnect from the people he crafted
his identity around he becomes a Hermit
and moves into a dingy trailer in the
outskirts of town I guess he was used to
the trailer life from his time on
Jennifer Jolie's driveway but it's still
a downgrade from the big house he once
shared with Gail Dewey has a habit of
revisiting the worst moments of his life
and he's had quite a few he also becomes
an alcoholic and it seems that his
personal issues began to affect his work
and eventually he was asked to resign
from the Woodsboro police department and
Deputy Hicks was promoted to sheriff
Hicks after spending his whole life
trying to earn respect they finally
stripped the last Accolade he had to his
name life became pretty sad for Dewey
with his sister's ashes on his mantle
the only thing he had to look forward to
every day was seeing his ex-wife show on
TV with no ghost face and no one he
cared about to protect Dewey felt that
he had lost his purpose he continued to
sink deeper until 2021 25 years since
Billy Loomis and Stu mocker first asked
what's your favorite scary movie
opportunity would come knocking at his
door Samantha Carpenter and her
boyfriend and definitely not Ghostface
Richie come around looking for an expert
in regards to a new set of ghostface's
hacks experts don't tempt typically
farewell and scream just ask Randy Meeks
Charlie and Robbie the fact that they
want to talk to him so badly even when
he doesn't want to get involved
illustrates that because of his
experiences he still has the respect of
the younger generation who desperately
need his help this is a small win for
Dewey but he's still skeptical give me
one good reason why I should talk to you
I'm Billy loomis's daughter
terrible reason for me to talk to you
while this is a Dewey broken as we have
ever seen him before his sympathetic
side gets the better of him and he gives
them a couple minutes to lay down The
rules there's certain rules to surviving
a stat movie
believe me I know
rule number one
never trust the love interest he's on
the money with that one after initially
being skeptical before adopting the
rules in Hollywood Dewey is now a
Believer he even seems to have mastered
the art of writing the rules rule number
two
Killer's motive
is always connected to Something in the
past I'm related to Billy yep Sam is
being set up solely because of her blood
relation to Billy Loomis in rule number
three and this is the most important
rule the first victim always has a
friend group that the Killer is a part
of damn this is the first time a
character has ever been 100 correct with
the rules usually the rules are more of
a best practices rather than something
set in stone Sam requests Dewey's Health
but he wants to stay far away from the
danger are you kidding me I've been
stabbed nine times I've got permanent
nerve damage and a fun little limp you
think I want to do that again nine times
so far but after some tough
contemplation he makes a call to Sydney
letting her know that it's happening
again and warning her to stay safe and
stay away not knowing that he's resigned
from the police she assumes that Dewey
is going to be protecting the next
generation of victims which makes him
reconsider his own actions was shutting
Sam and Richie out when he could
potentially help really something that
Dwight Riley would do next he has to man
up and call the ax Gail so he texts of
course ghost face is back don't come
here hope you're doing well he begins to
type out I still and we never see what
he's still but we can safely assume he
was about to say I still have your copy
of the Woodsboro murders with all the
pages cut through the center what would
you like me to do with it it must have
been Sydney's words combined with the
fact that he has nothing else to do in
his life that convinced Dewey to pull
out his trusty old handgun resting on
the same mantle of remembrance as his
tribute to Tatum and photo of Gail he's
symbolically reaching into the past one
more time he somehow finds where Sam and
Richie wins and offers his assistance he
finds himself in a suspect Roundup at
the home of Mindy and Chad mix the niece
and nephew of his old pal Randy where
naturally Dewey is suggested as a
suspect but what's my motive you got
stabbed a billion times got dumped by
your famous wife and crawled into a
bottle I think it's safe to say you're
on the suspect list well maybe you're
the Killer
because that cut deep ouch at least he
didn't call him dewdrop though Dewey
catches up on the attack so far and the
theme this time is familial connections
to the Past Tara was the first to be
attacked and her half-sister is Billy
loomis's daughter so she was also
attacked they both survived but
stumacher's nephew Vince wasn't so lucky
the pattern would continue later that
day when Sheriff Judy Hicks and her son
West are both killed in broad daylight
Dewey shows up at the crime scene to
grieve for his former deputy and friend
and perhaps do a little bit of
investigating on his own it is here
where he's spotted by gal with the
pressure of a new Ghostface
investigation forged renewed bonds
between them or would the reunion lead
to more fighting Dewey was quickly going
to find out
as is the tradition of their
relationship Dewey and Gail reunite
under morbid circumstances text ow tell
me the killers back in a text how that
hurts good he tries to justify it by
saying she was on the air at the time
and when he spots a camera crew with her
jabs back criticizing her for falling
back into her old ways of trying to
capitalize on tragedy for a good news
story it's the same argument they've had
since they met back in 1996. so
fittingly they're wearing the same
colors that they wore when they were
first formally introduced where there
was excitement in that first meeting
this reunion is tinged with sadness and
regrets Dewey expresses his shame at not
being able to last in New York City and
taking off in the middle of the night
it's the worst thing you can be in
Dewey's mind other than a murderer is a
coward you are a lot of things do we
but you are not a coward
just were meant to be in Woodsboro that
might not be it it's because he is in
Woodsboro and doing worse than ever
without his old friends there with him
he's living in a cemetery of everything
he's lost as Gail goes on camera for her
report it Dawns on Sam that no one's at
the hospital keeping an eye on Tara much
like Dewey didn't keep an eye on Sydney
in 1996 or Randy in 1997 and the two
speed off hoping to get there before
somebody else does in the car Dewey
listens in as Sam calls Richie but ends
up reaching someone with the infamous
ghost face voice on the other line
instead who gives her the choice of who
will survive her boyfriend or her sister
she stalls as they Park and get in the
elevator up towards Tara's room maybe
you're too weak for this franchise
or maybe I'm just stalling for time Ted
she probably shouldn't have said that if
Tara and the killer didn't happen to be
right on the other side of the elevator
door her sister would have been screwed
lucky for them when the doors slide open
and Dewey sees someone in a ghost face
costume and fires off a couple shots
which are evaded so Dewey and Ghostface
engage in melee slamming each other
around last flying looking back on this
the person in the ghost face costume
during the scene must be Amber who is
only 110 pounds or 49 kilograms throwing
all 161 pounds or 73 kilograms of Dewey
off her with some kind of Judo roll and
they said Scream 3 was supposed to have
the quote-unquote supernatural killer
speaking of which his Scream 3
experiences would come back to haunt him
here at first Dewey gets the upper hand
today
the head butts her backwards and grabs
the gun firing three shots into her body
dropping Amber into a bookcase do we
quickly escorts Sam Tara and Richie to
the elevator before remembering the
advice that Sydney gave him to help
defeat Roman more than 20 years
beforehand
what you have to shoot him
Dewey who gives them
I do no do it and the doors closed
leaving Dewey alone he turns and
unholsters his gun reloading as he walks
Clint Eastwood probably on his mind
stepping over broken glass to
ghostface's prone form Dewey aims when
his cell phone rings it's Gail the
momentary distraction gives Amber just
enough time to counter burying one knife
into his guts and the other fittingly
into the same spot on his back that
stumacher and Deborah Loomis had scarred
in the past she tears her knives from
Dewey's bodies simultaneously and kicks
his lifeless body to the ground
initially the way he was carried out on
the stretcher made me think he would
survive after all we've seen him exit a
Scream movie in similar fashion before
but then you start to realize you take
someone to the hospital to treat an
injury not away from it Dewey is headed
to the morgue Amber later explains that
they had to kill Dewey to give their
inevitable stab movie some weights and
try to prove that this wasn't just
another cash grab sequel given the
medicine and the nature of scream we can
assume that do his passing was an
intentional move by the new writers and
director to give their movie stays and
help launch a brand new chapter of
screen the SE death was devastating for
his surrogate family Sydney and gal for
25 years it had been Dewey who showed up
for that the only people his death could
have possibly been more devastating for
were his fans not since Randy Meeks had
the fandom been so incensed and shocked
at a scream death and it was because of
the actor David Arquette's parallels
with the character Dewey Riley that made
him feel so real for the audience David
Arquette put a lot of himself into Dewey
and his life began to parallel that of
the fictional character he portrayed
David met his eventual wife Courtney Cox
AKA Gail weathers at a pre-party before
the filming of the original screen like
their on-screen personas they fell in
love but it was not all smooth sailing a
year later in mid-june 1997 Courtney
allegedly detested him on the set of
scream 2. like Dewey and Gail David and
Courtney are very different people
scream 2 makes references to Cox's
friends co-stars David Schwimmer and
Jennifer Aniston probably an intentional
reference considering the Romantic
animosity between Dewey and Gail Scream
2 also features Dewey working with local
law enforcement and Sheriff Hartley is
played by David Arquette dad Lewis
Arquette the arcat family has been in
the film industry for Generations in
August of 1997 David's mother Brenda
Olivia Marty would pass away from breast
cancer creating another emotional link
to Dewey whose mother Mrs Riley is never
mentioned again in the series Scream 3
had Dewey and Gail finding their way
back to each other by the end and
committing the relationship to marriage
sure enough in real life David Arquette
and Courtney Cox were married one month
before Scream 3 began filming in 1999.
Dewey's statement about them never
working because they're too different
was a reality that David was facing with
Courtney David once said he was the live
wire and Courtney was his grounding
Force then on April 26 2000 David
Arquette would very controversially
become the world championship wrestling
heavyweight champ his belt status would
be hotly debated by wrestling fans with
David Arquette treated as a joke the
ballot was considered by most to be a
publicity stunt for arcat's wrestling
movie ready to rumble and David did not
gain the respect of real professional
wrestlers whatever that means however
Arquette was completely serious in his
efforts as a professional wrestler and
fought very hard to prove himself almost
to his death respect became a through
line in his life just as it did in
Deweys a decade later Arquette's
marriage to Courtney Cox was crumbling
and they were in couples therapy by the
time that the fourth scream was released
the Gulf of emotional distance between
them is reflected in Dewey and gal from
the top of scree form yes I pronounce
things how they are spelled their
relationship problems in the movie are
capped by an intense vow by Dewey to
never leave her again IRL it was just a
few months after shooting in October
2010 when David and Courtney were
separated the next decade wouldn't be
any easier than the last in 2011 he
entered rehab for alcohol and drugs and
in 2013 he and Courtney are legally
divorced once again this is all
reflected in the fifth scream which
gives details about Dewey Reilly
crawling into a bottle and ending his
marriage with Gail reflecting on their
divorce David Arquette stated on the
inside of our Rings it says it deals a
deal he says I felt really abandoned at
that point like she'd broken the deal
although it was reversed in the movie
for some reason Dewey was the one to
leave her David's life took another
mournful turn when his sister Alexis
Arquette died in September of 2018. two
months later David still in his bid to
earn the respect of the pro wrestling
world was sliced in the neck when his
opponent smashed a light tube over his
head in a live match in LA with concerns
David could bleed to death he was rushed
to the emergency room obviously he
survived to go on to be in Scream 2022
but his character in that movie really
did bleed to death in the ER I had this
one therapy session where I was talking
about my parents marriage and how it was
so hard on them then I realized both of
my parents are dead and all of this pain
is living inside me it was scream in
2022 that reunited Courtney and David on
screen in real life they're connected by
their daughter in the movie they are
connected by their past so there are
some real emotions flowing in the scene
where they come face to face in an
article by New York Times Arquette
acknowledged that being in a movie with
Cox again was inherently awkward it's
been 25 years of Our Lives he said we've
grown up together we have a child
together he explained however that he
could not pass it up it's a cathartic
experience just to be able to act
opposite coordinate when the cameras
rolled on their first scene together it
was a tearful moment and not just
because the script called for it Cox
said of our cats he got very emotional
while he was filming it he said the next
day the crew didn't look at him it's
insane how invested David Arquette is
with the character of Dewey Riley those
are real photos of our cat and Cox from
their real relationship on the mantle in
Scream 2022 scream was built on meta
commentary and became the flagship for
meta Cinema grief was already an
unspoken theme in Scream and is now
almost an entire genre on its own with
films like Midsummer hereditary the vich
and the babadook it's an amazing
meditation on motherhood and grief Dewey
became the scream representative of
grief and his real-life counterpart
David Arquette walked down that same
road alongside him in addition to the
wrestling incident there were many times
that David almost bit the dust himself
including a car crash and a heart attack
like his father and grandfather
beforehand talking to variety Arquette
had to say this on the controversial
final scene I mean you can't take Sydney
Sydney is a Survivor and and there was
something Noble about it for Dewey he
was there to protect Sydney and the
people of Woodsboro there was a scene
between Dewey and Gail and there was a
take they didn't use where I was super
emotional I sort of ad-libbed I'm a
failure I couldn't save Judy I couldn't
save my sister I think it was actually
too emotional like it was too much and a
lot of that emotion that I was going
through at that time was morning loss
the loss of West was heavy on our hearts
especially in that scene the only reason
Dewey even made it long enough to become
the hero be respected by the fandom and
become an authority within the franchise
is due to David Arquette's own drive to
be better and earn respect I'm sure the
OG 90s fandom will probably never stop
imagining different scenarios that bring
Dewey back as they have for Randy but no
matter how you slice it pun intended
Dewey was meant to die in Scream 2022
Against All Odds and maybe sense he
became the Clint Eastwood of screen the
town Hera riding out on his Bronco to
rid the west of Ghostface it if you want
more information on the meta Insanity
that is screened click on that playlist
on the left for my analysis of
characters like Randy Billy Loomis Casey
Becker and others remember to subscribe
to cz's world for new Horrors every week
unless it gets held up in review again
ring the death bell for all
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one assuming we both survive
[Music]